our next speaker
it's my pleasure to introduce my former
postdoc advisor Jeff McGee
Jeff is a professor at the Baylor
College of Medicine and Howard Hughes
medical investigator and uh Jeff did his
PhD at Tulane and then a move to Baylor
College of Medicine for his postdoc with
Dan Johnston who is the chair of my
thesis committee uh and uh he took his
first faculty position at LSU and he was
there until Hurricane Katrina hit the
city and then he moved briefly to the
University of Texas at Austin which is
where I met him while I was a graduate
student before starting as one of the
initial faculty members at Howard Hughes
medical institute's Genelia research
campus and then that's where I joined
him as a postdoc uh
13 long years ago I'm sorry really I
think it was 13.
so Jeff is a world leader in the field
of hippocampal competition and
specifically in subcellular Dynamics and
he's going to talk to us today about
some incredible recent work on memory
and learning in the hippocampus
okay thank you Mark
um
I'm gonna need a power adapter I didn't
bring mine if we could I'm gonna I'm
gonna need I don't see one up here
I only got 30 and maybe I can make it
but
the pressure might overwhelm me
thank you
Bartlett to the rescue
all right so
thank you Mark for that thank you Ela
for the invitation I'm excited about
icon
attacking this problem at multiple
levels is really I think an excellent
way to make some progress and so I I
would encourage you to pursue to pursue
that as much as possible we try to work
at three different levels and I find it
really overwhelming so you I think you
had six or seven there and so good luck
with that but uh pointer
no pointer okay
um all right so
um I spent a long time working on
dendrites when Mark was in the lab
that's pretty much all we did
um
more recently uh we're studying it thank
you again Bartlett uh
we're uh
studying a different function of
dendrites Maybe
just for the pointer
and um okay that's a problem but uh
just for the pointer you think
oh for the point
yeah
Perfect all right
two of them
um so yes we're trying to uh increase
our uh understanding of how brains learn
okay no again no small task and we're
sort of inching our way along uh
hopefully systematically and that's been
thought for a long time
that learning produces adaptive changes
in certain brain regions and of course
those
changes are adaptive because they
improve the behavior of the animal
okay and and so
um
it's also been thought are known for a
long time that those changes in a
particular brain regions are produced by
alterations in the strength of synaptic
connections between neurons in those
regions and this synaptic plasticity
Alters the input output transformation
there in a way that improves the
behavior
so now I'm going to just bring up two
issues that you could say complicate
this and the first is just pure numbers
okay and then little mouse hippocampal
sub-region I'm going to talk about there
are six billion synapses and of course
you know really astronomical numbers in
our brains and so it brings up the point
um how is it possible for these synaptic
plasticity mechanisms to find the right
synapses and change them appropriately
all within a short amount of time as
possible
uh and so this is one problem and the
other one is is probably an even bigger
issue something that you know you're all
familiar with and that's what I've
labeled synapse depth and we'll just use
this little
multi-layer three-layer network uh as an
analogy here it's not a very good one
but it'll serve the purpose uh here's
the input layer at the bottom I think of
uh sensory input coming in here and then
these synapses these cells
uh make synapses onto the middle or
hidden layer and then the middle hidden
layer makes synapses on the output layer
the output of which drives some action
so of course multi-layer networks are
quite powerful because they can produce
complex input output transformations
the trick is of course how to change
these six billion synapses in light of
the fact that there are 60 billion other
synapses and parameters
Downstream of them between them and the
output region whose output you're trying
to optimize by changing the weights of
all of these synapses
of course heavy and plasticities aren't
up to this task because they're blind to
all of these Downstream parameters
okay what's needed is some kind of
additional signal
that brings back information about these
parameters uh and um and and helps
assists this synaptic plasticity process
right here this is of course back prop
and artificial neural networks as
suffice it to say that it is a
completely unknown how this works or
what this signal is in real brains
okay so that's what I'm going to talk
about is a little adaptive change in
hippocampal population activity that
occurs during a very simple Behavior a
simple learning behavior in mice and
then I'll point out the Snap synaptic
plasticity that's responsible for this
adaptive change and and then we'll go
into some detail about the properties of
the instructive signal that is directing
the plasticity okay so here's the
behavior
we work in mice uh their head pigs mice
here's one an old one back in the day
when Mark was with us from sebroyer and
you can see that this mouse is on a
treadmill the treadmill's got some
features on it and they're trained to
run a lap about 2 meters 180 centimeters
and stop and lick their water reward
okay very very very simple but that's
the learning that's what they learn
where to run to and stop and lick and
I'll show you some behavioral data in a
minute during this we're going to make a
one of either two kinds of recordings so
first I'll show you some population
recordings from a set of about three or
four hundred neurons pyramidal cells in
ca1 and you can see the world famous
place sells from six of these as shown
here you can see that they tile the
environment essentially this is these
are calcium signals of course that rise
and fall because the action potential
firing rate of these cells Rises and
falls
here's one of these Place Fields is now
in location and you can see the heat
maps of the place throughout the firing
rate if you will for all of these six
neurons here and they've been sorted so
that they tile the environment you're
going to see a lot of these
in the next 30 minutes so that's what
they look like the activity has been
Peak scale
okay so here's the behavior it's very
simple Christina is going to have you
know several days of sort of
pre-training where the animals on a belt
that is blank it has none of these
somatosensory cues on it and the reward
position on the Belt changes uh from lap
to lap
and you can see here's the licking each
one of these little ticks is a lick and
the Animals just looking all over the
place trying to find the reward and
they're running it rather a uniform a
constant yet slow velocity across the
track
and here are a population of 400 or so a
ca1 place cells that are recorded
simultaneously with this behavior and
you can see again they've been sorted by
the position of their place field and
there's a uniform tiling of the entire
environment now next day is learning day
she changes the environment by putting a
bunch of cues that you saw before on the
belt and fixes the reward right in the
middle here and you can see the
evolution of the licking is quite
rapidly certainly by you know 30 40 50
trials the animal has figured out where
the reward is and only looks right there
that's the behavior okay and it occurs
you know within uh 10 minutes
and uh and what also changes uh is that
the animal begins to slow down and stop
and like you saw on the video around the
reward to consume the reward and then
begins running again now we look at the
same set of animals same Fields
microscope field same neurons
and we can see that there's about two
three times as many Place cells now and
that there's this huge over
representation at the reward site again
nearly threefold increase in the density
of place cells that have their place
fields around the reward
okay so there's an experienced dependent
shaping of the representation a lot of
other people study this and have seen
this before this group has seen that if
they do an optogenetic manipulation that
removes this over-representation then at
this learning this evolution of licking
also doesn't happen so we would call
this an Adaptive change
okay so this is our adaptive change in
hippocampal activity
now what's going on I told you there was
about two or three times as many Place
fields
on at the end of day one as uh from the
beginning and what's basically happening
is there are new place Fields appearing
uh during the session okay and they're
four characteristics four or five
characteristics of these new place
fields that are relevant to what I'm
going to tell you and uh so the first is
that they you can see here they they
just sort of pop out okay they're
abruptly they appear abruptly so no real
hints that there's any kind of activity
already here they're not sort of ramping
up over time they just boom appear okay
and many people in the hippocampal world
see Place cells that do this
now the other thing is you'll see that
they tend to shift back in space in this
case we're in space so the first field
is here and then on the subsequent two
or three it moves back and stays there
and the same is here it moves back and
stays there okay and so there's this
predictive shift so step back in space
next you can already see as well is that
depending on the running speed of the
animal and when the place field appears
the width of the place field changes as
well okay the faster they run the wider
the field that's going to result
okay
and finally uh all of this and the
development of the over-representation
and the increase in the number of
placeholds all the Adaptive changes can
be blocked by changes in different drugs
which block plasticity in these uh
regions like an MDA receptor antagonist
and and a Blocker of r-type calcium
channels are even l-type calcium
channels we'll remove these adaptive
changes
Okay so
let's see so
um I don't really have time to go into
this too much I'm going to show you
quickly what I'm talking about in a
minute but synaptic plasticity we found
over the past 10 years or so that these
Place fields are are driven by a
synaptic plasticity okay there's a ramp
of depolarization of the membrane
potential
that crosses threshold and produces then
action potential firing at a particular
location that ramp of depolarization is
produced by an enhanced weights of the
synaptic input the excitatory synaptic
inputs that's coming in okay so I'm
going to show you one example and then a
little bit of population data and then
cut to the cartoon okay it's unfortunate
but if you like to talk to me more
detail about it I'd be happy to all
right so
this is the other way that we record
from these animals and that is wholesale
voltage recordings while the animal is
doing the same thing that I've already
showed you what's going to happen is the
animal is going to be running these laps
and here's the VM and and then the
position of the animal from zero to 180
centimeters is in red and then there's
an extracellular voltage that's been
filtered at Theta Band frequencies a
dendritic calcium Spike dendritic
calcium Plateau potential is going to
occur on one trial and then in the next
trial there'll be a place field there
okay and these these Plateau potentials
occur out in the distal apical dendrite
so here we go I gotta hold it down to
make it go twice as fast
you can see there's one lap there's
essentially no place field there and
this is the animal standing nothing's
going on there's a little bit of firing
while the animal's standing and when it
starts running uh there's you know a
flat line on the VM we'll do one more uh
pre-lap some firing while the animals
standing and then okay again nothing
and then on the next trial
you'll see Plateau potential go off
you'll notice nothing out here no spikes
and then on the next trial you'll see
increased depolarization in a place
field on the next lap
these are current injections to check
input resist serious resistance and
um and the place field is there I think
I got one more I'll do one more lap
there it is a nice place field that's
developed and then the animal actually
forgets to stop and the place field is
even smaller
um okay
so here's all of the data
all the laps you can see the first 10
trials nothing then Plateau potential
goes off there's no action potentials or
anything before you know of course
there's something going on with this
giant calcium Spike and then afterwards
there's a place field that stays for the
additional 20 minutes of the animals on
the track
and that's what the plateau looks like
at the Soma it's basically you know a 50
or 60 millivolt uh 500 millisecond long
uh calcium channel mediated action
potential out in the dendrites that
propagate semi uh actively throughout
the entire neuron broadcasting This
Global signal
and um here are these average of these
trials in Gray and now we've bend them
in space there's a little bit of time
bins as well so you can see before and
here's what uh after uh the the plateau
um you can see that there's a very large
ramp of depolarization so these are the
VMS that have been medium filtered that
takes the spikes off and so you can just
see this underlying ramp of
depolarization quite large in this case
we can subtract these two things
and use a Time base based on the running
during this one trial when the plateau
potential went off it's referenced to
that so it takes four seconds to run
from the very beginning of the track to
the plateau and then another two or
three seconds from the plateau to the
end okay and then what you can see then
is so this is just a subtraction of
these two traces that this change in the
membrane potential is covering about six
seconds
okay so it's a multi-second long
plasticity and that it is also
asymmetric in that it's projecting
further back than forwards
okay and you can see that the peak is
actually shifted as well so it produces
the first the second thing that I showed
you first of all uh it's abrupt okay
it's abrupt because these Plateau
potentials are so strong bam one time
and you get a place field you get all
the plasticity
it causes the place field to shift back
because of this asymmetric plasticity
kernel okay and uh and then it's
operating on the seconds time scale so
uh you know depending on how fast the
animal is running the width will also
vary accordingly all of this can be
blocked by again an MDA receptor
antagonists both in Vivo and in vitro as
well as calcium channel blockers
um here's from the population against
asymmetric covering multiple seconds
these are all cells that didn't have
really much of a ramp we call them
silent cells because they're silent but
not only that they don't have much of
even a sub threshold change in the
membrane potential
so about two-thirds of these we've
actually injected current into to drive
the plateau potentials okay so if we
have a cell like this and we inject
current somewhere else then when a cell
that has already has a place field
then the initial Place field will get
smaller let's say we injected current
here the initial Place field would get
smaller and this part would increase in
depolarization so the plasticity is not
just a potentiation it's also a
depression it's bi-directional and
they're happening both at the same time
and you can see that here if there's
already a place cell and we either add
Plateau potentials or one happens
spontaneously then you can also see in
addition to less potentiation you get
this obvious depression component as
well this negative change in the
membrane potential
Okay so
as I'll show you in a second that means
that the the the sort of equilibrium
amount of plasticity that you're going
to get is dependent upon the weights
that are already there the current
weights uh in uh in the in the vector of
this one cell okay so this is this is a
place cell because there's a
depolarization this depolarization is
there is because the weights of these
inputs are higher so now they can uh be
de-potentiated if you will
all right so here's the cartoon then and
uh we will start off with just sort of
the basic heavy and idea here's the
postsynaptic cell here's a presynaptic
cell uh correlated input output you get
plasticity we call this plasticity that
I've just showed you uh btsp behavioral
time scale synaptic plasticity and it
requires additional components one is a
new compartment okay we need an apical
dendrite and we also need a new voltage
signal instead of just having an output
signal that's driving the plasticity
changes in the weights we're going to
have a plateau potential which is more
or less solely responsible for producing
plasticity it's not really an output
signal it's just a plasticity signal
just a plasticity signal
and then we're going to need an
additional input whose job is mainly to
drive the plasticity through Plateau
potential initiation
okay and then we're also going to need
some biochemical signals to stretch this
thing out in time some filters of both
the synaptic input and the plateau
potential
I'll just tell you that we've been
trying to figure these out it's not easy
and we really haven't made any progress
that's the bottom line on that
it's it's biochemistry and that's that's
a little out of our wheelhouse and this
is what we're talking about if you get
too down in the wrong layer then you
know things start to go sour on you but
hopefully somebody else can uh can can
configure these things out because this
is still theoretical okay there's very
little evidence of these biochemical
signals now uh until the lashansi's lab
has published something recently uh with
uh with Fred Frank Polo um that that
showed that there may be an involvement
of calcium release calcium induced
calcium release that may be involved
with this
constructive signal
anyway
um the cartoon uh the cartoon equation
is here uh the change into weights uh is
basically here's the heart of the matter
the overlap of these two biochemical
signals okay and so this determines
which synapses this is the pick which
synapses are going to change exactly
which direction and how much is
dependent on to overlap as well and then
uh how far away this is the potentiation
component here in this case if if the
potentiation these are the weights that
are already there this is the current
weight if it's high of course then this
potentiation is going to be small if
it's low it can be quite large and then
there's just a sort of balance of this
by the depression component which again
is scaled by the current weights here's
here's the paper Aaron's paper in E-Life
where the real equation lives and you
can go and see that
yeah is that enough
um
that's the plasticity
and uh now you know some details I hope
you like details oh and uh this
instructive pathway and where is it
coming from what's it doing and what
kind of signal is it and
um
so you know we we knew from from the
past work that and just sort of bloody
obvious Anatomy uh where to look uh in
Toronto cortex layer three neurons are
pyramidal cells and they they project a
pathway that you know almost exclusively
innervates uh the distal apical tuft of
these cells where this Plateau potential
is initiated
so uh Christina is going to do an
optogenetic experiment now she doesn't
want to blast the whole network and
she's trying to make a subtle change so
that the behavior doesn't change and
that you know this is a loop somehow
it's not very direct but the EC in this
hippocampus are tied together so she
doesn't want to inadvertently change the
afferent input the feed forward input as
well so she's going to use a retrograde
virus to just infect uh the ECS cells
that are sending their axons into this
particular region of the hippocampus
it's also going to infect and Express
gcamp in that same region and record
from this population of pyramidal cells
put a light fiber in uh that you see to
activate the archaea rhodopsin or under
at least the control conditions just
cells that are expressing tomato there's
a light fiber you turn the light on
around the reward location
run the animal and do everything normal
and there's basically no effect
okay you can see the over-representation
in the middle and then in the test group
then
with the archae rhodopsin she has more
or less inhibited the activity of a
small subset of EC cells and changed
removed the Adaptive change the
plasticity in the ca1 hippocampal region
okay
manipulate an external region and change
the plasticity in in this one region
really nice
and you can see that's Quantified there
okay so something's going on in the AC
it's somehow uh sending uh some input
that's helping to drive or direct this
plasticity in in ca1
next step is to record from these axons
and see what kind of activity they have
and bottom line is there's about five
and maybe less than ten percent that
shows some decent spatial selectivity
but most of them are these kind of
crappy uh sloppy Place specific
cells that have some specific firing at
a particular location and the world you
can see uh you know here's one cell mini
trials position that I didn't leave well
here it is position and you can see that
you know there's a stochasticity to this
firing that's a little bit weird okay
and so that led us to try to look at the
distribution of these on times and off
times
and it's true that you know you need
hundreds of these openings and there's
only 20 cells out of a thousand that we
had this many uh transitions in but in
those uh cells um uh the the there is an
exponential distribution of uh the on
and off at times of these cells so
bottom line is uh there's some moderate
tuning moderate spatial tuning of the EC
input with hints of some kind of
non-standard activity okay so here's
another hint of non-standard activity uh
here's all of the you know 800 cells for
this we're still in the same environment
okay that I showed you before
and here's the average of the odd lap
trial zero two four six eight Etc and
you can see they've been sorted
according to the location of their Peak
and then if we look at the same cells
sort of the same way but for the
intervening lapse one three five nine
you can see that uh you know there's
there's some stochasticity there they're
not very stable but there is you know
there is a little hint of stability here
and then if we plot these uh locations
for the even the peak locations for the
even laps versus the odd laps it's not
exactly a shotgun blast but uh pretty
close there is only 20 percent of these
cells that have some stability to their
finding we made a model of all this
activity in order to try to understand
how it would be summed up
postsynaptically in Drive Plateau
potentials unfortunately I don't have
time to talk about that but uh
be happy to answer questions about it at
any time the basic idea is that we just
reproduce uh you know it's a very simple
model okay but it really captures a lot
of the activity in an amazing way
2000 two-state Markov chains with a
little bit of tweaking on the transition
probabilities the activation probability
to produce the sloppy tuning and then we
just distribute them equally uniformly
across space okay and that matches the
data this is basically a quantification
of that and the model does the same
thing now in the model
we can simulate the mouse running at a
constant rate and lo and behold there is
a constant rate of plateaus that are
initiated across the track okay not
surprising what is interesting about
this is how low this rate is okay so
it's 0.5 times 10 to the minus 3 per
second per cell so there's 10 000
postsynaptic cells in this case 50 laps
10 seconds that gives you about 2500
Plateau potentials 2500 new place cells
out of ten thousand so even at this
incredibly low rate you can
significantly change the number of place
cells that are in in the population just
for comparison if you had 40 percent
four thousand of your cells were Place
cells and they had 10 Hertz firing for
one second you get a thousand times more
action potentials than you would Plateau
potentials okay so it is a very low rate
of occurrence of plateau potentials
which fits with the data now if the n
animals obviously not running at a
constant speed but is slowing down
around the reward site here's the real
data for that average of 14 animals and
if we use that instead of this constant
rate then you can see that the constant
rate of plateau potentials where an
animal is actually dwelling for twice as
long as long around the reward will give
you twice as many Plateau potentials
twice as many Place cells at that
location okay it's that simple
and so that's our prediction of what all
of this activity should give you in
terms of a representation in ca1
here's the actual representation in ca1
and black and now this is in Gray you
can see that yeah it's in the right
place it's twofold but the data is
actually a three-fold increase
and you know there is a significant
correlation here now you can say oh well
you know this was a very simple model
you're lucky to have gotten that and
that's pretty much what we said but
there is a difference and and that was
going to show you here there's actually
a little more tuning of the cells around
the reward site are actually a little
bit more tuned and um maybe that's
what's going on there or maybe we should
just
count our lucky stars and move on which
is what we did
so bottom line is uh there's a uniform
distribution of these moderately tuned
cells so that plus the running behavior
of the animal basically explains uh the
change or the type of distribution of uh
Place cells that we see in the ca1
representation now it also suggested to
us that uh you know you can remember the
somatosensory cues were were uniformly
distributed across the track okay so we
thought maybe that uniform distribution
of these EC of the EC activity is you
know representing that uniform
distribution of the cues and the
environment and so we're going to switch
and try to test that we're going to
remove all the cues and uh and have a
blank belt and just use a a light
stimulus 50
centimeters in front of the reward so
it's predictive and it's strong it's
novel animals never seen this it's a
flashing light right in its eyes 10
Hertz you can see that the licking
behavior is subtly changed but not too
dramatically but that the running
behavior is quite different okay so
here's what I just showed you in Black
for environment a and now an environment
B the animal starts to slow down around
the light stimulus and then just
continues to gradually slow and then
continue on after the reward
so what do we get from the EC now 800
cells again the same idea here's the
even trial the eye trials and then the
average of the even trials
you can again see that uh you know there
there's a lot of stochasticity still
left in this but you can see the shadow
here now there's about three or five
times as many of these cells and again
on this plot here right at the site of
uh of the light that we didn't see
before
okay here this is Quantified again
there's about a four-fold increase in
the density of EC cells who Peak whose
Peak activity is around the light
there's the model in the lighter colors
which are difficult to see
um
so that's the model and then you know we
do the same thing with the actual
running versus the constant here's the
prediction of the plateaus in the
postsynaptic population you can see that
there is a difference again the running
is making a difference but because
there's just it's not just as distinct
as it was before in the environment a
there's not as big of a difference and
and really there's a big change in the
density of plateaus around the light
that kind of tapers off slowly as you go
now what so that's the prediction of
what the ca1 should look like the
distribution of place cells in the in
the ca1 in this new environment here it
is you can see the over-representation
there here it is Quantified there's
about a two three-fold increase in uh
the ca1 place cells around the light
less of an effect maybe 75 percent
increase versus you know two to
threefold increase in B uh here are the
uh the the prediction in light colored
red from the model and then the actual
uh from the ca1 data in uh in the darker
color again there's a significant
correlation between those two so it
looks like then that the EC is adjusting
itself its activity to the density or
the distribution of relevant cues in the
environment and using that as a training
signal or teaching signal
to tell the hip to shape the type of
representation that's present in ca1
all right last slide
um
what kind of uh instructive signal is
this is it a error signal like we would
expect like in the purkinje cells and
and the cerebellum
so here's something that I didn't show
you before uh here's uh the number or
the fraction of place cells new place
cells that are appearing during the
trial okay so you can see in these
sections of 25 laps that about three
quarters of the cells that are going to
appear appear within the first 25 trials
and then this drops Like a Rock such
that by 50 trials there's essentially no
plus very little plasticity left
okay so whoops if
If This Were an error signal we would
expect it to track uh this uh same sort
of plasticity profile here instead our
measure of EC activity in both
environments uh stays relatively
constant okay so this suggests to us
that this is not an error signal coming
in from the internal cortex and that
it's probably more like a desired or
Target a signal that's coming in okay
and so we can make the control system
analogy the weak analogy again where we
have uh you know here's the components
of this here again the basis set comes
up from so there's a feed forward input
from a ca3 I've already tuned Place
cells and then there's a Target coming
in from the torontal cortex there's a
population activity in ca1 that's fed
back through
somatostatin positive olm interneurons
who again exclusively innervate the tuft
of these pyramidal cells in ca1 this is
uh and obviously an inhibitory input and
so the uh apical dendrite tuft of these
cells this distal region of the tree is
acting like a comparator for these two
activities in two different brain
regions okay the activity in the
intrinal cortex is compared with the
activity in the ca1 Via this feedback
inhibition and if the target exceeds the
inhibition the actual then there's an
error local in each individual pyramidal
cell and that error is the plateau
potential okay the plateau potential
then produces plasticity
that changes the actual ca1 activity
okay and so if we look at this
in time we remove the real data and put
the cartoon up that's always nice we can
see the activity from the target from
the EC is up here where the activity in
in ca1 is down here there's a difference
in the activity this produces a large
amount of plasticity in ca1 and Plateau
potentials that increases the uh the
activity in or just brings it closer in
space to uh to the Target that reduces
the plasticity and turns everything off
okay so as these two activities approach
each other this reduces the error signal
in the individual local regions of ca1
pyramidal cells and cuts the plasticity
off
all right so that's it there it is in
space same idea
um
I'll spare you this basically it's that
it appears that the internal cortex in
this case is collecting you know
external input and internal input from
self-motion and maybe decision making
areas or something and producing a kind
of quick and dirty uh estimation of
what's important in the world and that
that's using and then sending out
targets based upon this sort of quick
and dirty understanding about the
aspects of the world to train the
hippocampus which in the end you know
shapes itself depending on what the
hippocampus and what the EC thinks is
important and because all of this
plasticity produces shifts in the place
Fields these are now predictions and so
one of the ideas is actually these
predictions May then be targets
themselves that get sent broadcast
throughout the entire brain to help it
learn as well
um all right so let me mention Christina
she did almost everything that I showed
you today and uh she's your neighbor now
up at Brandeis uh she's very talented uh
look her up sometime and then uh you
know slash and did uh some of uh the G
Camp Imaging eding and another student
in the lab of course with Katie I did
all of the uh wholesale recordings and
Randy keeps things running we still have
a lot of good interactions with our old
colleagues at Genelia thanks
foreign
thank you Jeff that was great um I'm
wondering about given that the synaptic
weight affects the expression of btsp
when you expose the animal to a second
new environment is there a relationship
in the same cells of their new preferred
Place field
is there a relationship with what in the
in the if you have you know new place
Fields forming in that second
environment yeah do you see a
correlation
a prior a memory yes
um we're looking at that that's all I
can say that's what Sasha's working
Sasha's working on
very Savvy Jeff
I can't say anything could kill me
yes
I
yeah
um thank you Jeff that was really really
interesting
um this this rapid drop off in
uh Place field formation that happens
like you know you get a lot and then
suddenly there's very little yeah is
that because the uh the internal cortex
is sending out fewer blasts uh or is
that because the blasts are not being
registered or not doing anything
um well
so
probably just the way that I expressed
this made it look a little more jumpy
than it is this is in blocks okay so
it's 25 then 25 trials but the point is
that uh the EC activity really isn't
changing I just showed you a very simple
sort of overall sum of the average but
the population Vector isn't changing
much at either as the animal you know
goes through the entire session so it
has to be something else that's uh
that's turning the plasticity off and
that that's what we that's that's where
the control system thing comes in where
the the feedback from the o o l m enter
neurons which innervate the plateau
these are somatostatin positive cells
like martinati cells actually shuts down
every all the plasticity of the plateaus
nothing changes in the EC
it still thinks okay this is what you
should be doing
but if you if you took the mouse and you
put it in a different environment like
after after 25 trials then it would
still be able to learn the new
environment it would still be I mean it
would you could learn constantly just
doesn't like to learn more in the same
environment is that that's correct and
the idea would be just that the activity
of ca1 is approaching the target
okay and that so if you put it in a new
environment then the target would change
and that would drive new plasticity and
so this is oversimplified okay there's
obviously other things attentional
modulation and and other things like
that that are going to be involved okay
and we don't and this is the most
theoretical part of it we don't really
know what's shutting it off but this is
our Theory and and Aaron's made a model
of this in this paper as well and it
works um and so uh
that's the idea Bartlett that there's
some component within the network that's
shutting the plasticity off as the
activities come together
yeah
thank you
um so so you discovered a new type of
plasticity right the btsp yeah in Vivo
um
and people have been trying to look at
plasticity and vitro and slices for many
many years so so what is the implication
of this do you expect that we will find
many more different many more different
plasticity rules that we couldn't find
before in vitro or can you tell us a
little bit why how you're able to do
that I think there are enough plasticity
in vitro rules hopefully we won't find
too many more
um this this one is in in Vivo this one
shows up in Vivo we haven't done the the
LTD the the depotentiation portion of it
but we need to
um you know hopefully other people will
start looking at other brain areas the
neocortex would be interesting to see if
this is present in other pyramidal base
circuits like Marlin showed you this is
a canonical theme it's the same circuit
here as it is everywhere so this could
happen layer five cells are a little bit
different they're like twice as long and
there's more complicated stuff going on
on so it'd be really interesting to see
if it's going on there now I will tell
you we've we've looked at least in Vivo
in the previous hippocampal stage and
this is also there there's a plateau
based seconds long plasticity that's
responsible for Place fields in ca3
we've toyed around with other pyramidal
subiculum things like this and it seems
to be there as well
so this is uh you know I think at least
in the hippocampus it's established now
and multiple Labs have seen it the
question I think is how widespread it is
is it going to be just hippocampus is it
going to be neoportex two just pyramidal
cells how about the granule cells how
about stellate cells things like that so
you know I would encourage everybody to
do this it's not the easiest thing in
the world to get a calcium spike in a
slice it takes modulation and then you
got to deal with all this other changes
constantly changing conditions if you
dump muscarino or something like that
and so you know we may have to refine
the conditions but I would still you
know whoever's interested in this this
is a very different form of plasticity
and learning than standard heavy and
kinds of things that people that all of
us really myself included studied for 50
years so it's worth looking into
thank you
I thought it was the
uh
that's cool
yeah
foreign
[Music]
s okay I mean so it still occurs over 50
trials you know tens of minutes
and and it is only discrete in the
individual cells which in the past were
the heavy and kinds of plasticities stdp
and all of these things it would take
dozens of these trials in the individual
cells So Not only would the overall
population be slowly evolving but the
individual neurons within the population
would be slowly expressing this
plasticity as well which may be very
important you know Behavior
developmentally okay to develop to
develop these different receptive Fields
probably is doing something heavy and
over many weeks or something like that
but in this case it is it is abrupt and
sudden within the individual neurons
and that allows the whole population to
evolve more rapidly but not not over the
individual we're only talking a few you
know tens of cells within the whole
population per trial something like that
well so this is the level of the
population it's not as sharp it just
looks like it here this is 50 trials in
okay it's two points but we've done it
this way
and what does correlate with this is
that licking Behavior okay so if you
plotted these two versus The Evolution
of the licking the number of the
fraction of licks outside of the reward
site they they map you know almost
perfectly
now you know we don't like to you know I
don't really like to talk about that in
the paper or anything like that because
then it's obvious you should do that
experiment and you know we don't really
want to try to block out other people
have already done that experiment it's
hard to block hippocampuses this huge
sprawling thing and to to actually you
know manipulate the whole thing it's not
that easy and so we haven't done that
but other people have
okay thanks a lot
[Applause]